supercars the ultimate driving machine
oh this this car is ridiculous the power
in it is unbelievable
this year supercar dealers have seen
sales top the 4 billion pound mark when
i'm that race i can just blow my nose on
them
i am selling celebrities footballers
people in the music industry
even actors
but who are the men and women who make
millions from selling these cars without
sounding too big headed about things i
couldn't spend the money i've got if i
wanted to
what's in the suitcase
you cut me open
you've not got blood coming on me you've
got super
unleaded fuel coming on me pumping out
what methods do they use to clinch the
million pound deal he needs a car to
take his wife out and then he needs a
car take his girlfriend out
this is the girlfriend oh my god do you
know when i sell a car to a lady you
don't honestly think we talk about cars
do you we talk about shiny red soles
if i'm in bed if i'm in the shower if i
remember trainers no i wouldn't take 480
thousands 500 000 sterling phone rings
is the deal to be done i'll do it
and how easy is it to succeed in the
cutthroat world of supercar sales how
much does he pay for this 217 000. once
i remember i paid a million pounds too
much for a ferrari
[Music]
at 1
hundred thousand pounds take your time
it's a lot of money
an exclusive auction house in the center
of london
some of the world's most desirable cars
are being fought over by some of the
world's most wealthy people
1
650
000 pounds
it's here that top supercar salesman
like tom hartley and his son carl can be
seen hoping to pick up a
bargain hold on
congratulations
essentially we own a big toy shop
we buy and sell toys to people who want
to play
a top supercar salesman can make
millions of pounds a year we deal in
the most expensive
supercars in the world
we deal with the rich we deal with the
famous
with the royalty
the elite elite
[Music]
53 year old tom hartley is regarded by
many as one of the most successful
supercar salesmen in the country we sold
a car
that reached a world record price
40 million dollars
i'm not sure that's been beat today
[Music]
home for tom hartley is a specially
designed 40-acre estate deep in the
derbyshire countryside when you come to
them gates it's been described as the
latter's cave
there are two seven-bedroom mansions a
helipad and arguably one of the most
spectacular garages in the country this
was
elton john's
original uh car yet it knew
but it was brand new
um it's a bit of a classic quarter of a
million pounds with the help of his 27
year old son carl tom hartley sells up
to four million pounds worth of vintage
and new supercars each week this is a
ferrari 458 spider
um this car was actually a very bespoke
car because of the specification the
paint alone is 9 000 pounds
this is 200 000 pounds
the lamborghini aventador probably the
leading in-demand
super rich
car to buy
and it's 250 000 pounds
good morning it's said to get morning is
that um mr lisey
it's tom hartley how are you
dad tom left school at the age of 11 and
has been dealing every day since i'm
obsessed about doing deals i'm obsessed
about buying and selling because as part
of my life that's why i am a buy and
sell i'm a deal maker
[Music]
like his father carl didn't go to
secondary school instead his dad thought
he could give him a better education on
his showroom floor
he used to sit here
i used to be like you know who was that
and how much how much do you want to pay
and how much is it for sale for and how
much how much did you buy the car for
he's my role model as such you know he's
someone you learn from he's you know
he's
everything i know and i know because
i've well the majority of what i know i
know because i've learned from him hello
how do you do good thank you
carl is now a co-owner in the company he
mostly buys supercars for the business
monday morning and carl is off to
scotland to buy a ferrari
while dad tom is in london where he will
try to nail his biggest deal of the year
there's a car here for 12
12.5 million euros casino owner mr
thomas is looking to invest six and a
half million pounds in an assortment of
classic cars this is a ferrari detourner
a spider that's coming up
now that's about two million
what's in the suitcase
cash
so why are multi-millionaires buying
these cars
the old cars aren't being made anymore
they're all classics they like this
they're van goghs they're monas
mayonnaise the chinese market's waking
up to classic cars the russian market
eastern european it's a lot of people a
lot of money and very limited stock
don't want anything to chief's wrong
word
i wouldn't give you that that's what
i've said to you
the six and a half million pound deal
has not been done
tom's been sent away to find better cars
supercars are the ultimate in boys toys
and almost all supercar dealers are men
but there are some women who choose to
enter this
testosterone-fueled world this is the
458 that we've sold saba amari runs a
supercar showroom in preston
i
prep is um quite in-depth
so you know we we clean in places where
most people uh most most dealers
wouldn't but i suppose
it's gonna sound really sexist on tv but
that's a woman's church
it just feels great
to be that one person
that's not the stereotype that's not the
typical rule
all right don't don't dream too much of
the car then over the weekend yeah
okay bye-bye
thanks bye
there we go that's one happy customer
coming on monday afternoon
to hopefully do the deal on rf12
sabha admits that she uses her feminine
charm to sell cars and demonstrates it
on a friend
you know it's a car that you can just
jump in it's an enjoyment car absolutely
yeah absolutely my focus is actually on
the whole lifestyle choice than than
just the vehicle i firmly believe that
anyone coming in to buy a car has
already decided whether they want it or
not then you live once you work hard
yeah you know come on
they're buying into a lifestyle of
luxury aren't they
sabba's seeing more and more women
buying supercars
i find whenever when a lady picks up the
phone or comes into the showroom she
knows exactly what she wants women have
very good taste in cars do you know when
i sell a car to a lady you don't
honestly think we talk about cars do you
we talk about shiny red souls that's
what we talk about all the time and
handbags
and holidays
saber doesn't run this business alone
she does it with her husband known
simply as a maori part of the job
description of my wife is to
do my do my hair as well what style
would you like to do
the couple married 12 years ago
and now have two children
[Music]
we have bunny and clyde that's what we
are
or mr and mrs smith
with i'm brad pitt and she's angelina
jolie
i wanted to be brad pitt yeah
touch cars i am a car fanatic the
amari's have big plans to expand and
build another multi-million pound
showroom the new show would be
absolutely fantastic when a customer
buys and buys a car the cars will come
down a glass lift you know with a cover
on it you know and then there'll be four
girls you know around the car beautiful
girls you know and then they'll take the
covers off and then the music will come
on and they'll start dancing around the
car and what does your wife think of the
dancing girl i'm not happy about it at
all
yeah it's not been approved at director
level yet
at the end of the day they even argue
over which supercar they might like to
drive home
porsche
about three three four four porsches i
know aston martin sabha likes the new
cars but her husband prefers
classics
to
vintage
i'll give them it's important to me what
other people think definitely let's take
the rolls-royce phantom there
and sabha usually gets her own way
[Applause]
it's a big day for supercar salesman tom
hartley casino owner mr thomas is on his
way to view more cars but first what's
it like in the hartley house
this is a heartless residence and this
is uh
this is the living room
there's twenty
eight rooms in this house fourteen
thousand square foot
seven bedrooms have all got this
equipment and all got sound system
in every room
this is a cinema room do a lot of
entertaining in here
this one room cost 250 000 pounds to
develop
this is me and my wife when i was fifty
three years ago i think i look younger
than i did
casino owner mr thomas has arrived
this is what i'd like to include
[Music]
yeah just just stylish and it's chic
tom's been busy buying more supercars in
the hope that they will impress mr
thomas enough to spend his six and a
half million pound investment fund
this is a 250 ferrari recreation
test roaster
this is a million sterling
reproduction yes it will give you a
return you don't have to include it if
you want to i'd like to include it
is mr thomas willing to part with his
millions
the relentless rise of the supercar a
four billion pound industry fueled by
the desire to go from north to sixty
miles per hour in just over three
seconds
selina is a supercar fanatic with a
garage full of ferraris it's thrilling
it's exciting it's
it's the dream
you know that you do have to pinch
yourself and remind yourself that yes
you do own these cars
[Music]
jonty loves his supercar so much he's
put it in his living room
this is my uh ferrari 308gtb and this is
where i keep it
yanny's specially wrapped his ferrari in
gold
just to drive just the feeling you just
feel
you feel special you feel nice that
you're you're in this sort of car and
you've worked hard to get there
the increasing demand for these cars
means more and more dealers are trying
to get in on the act good morning big
costume speaking of it
even ordinary garages are seeing an
opportunity to make some serious money
because else can we help you at all
essex dealership big cars normally sell
everything from fiestas to bmws but boss
adam has decided to splash out 300 000
pounds on three supercars for this new
showroom
[Music]
the reason we're moving part of our
business in that direction
is because we know that there's a market
for it i certainly
through running the business of seeing
people screaming out for this kind of
cars yeah
impressive
very impressive
not one of the big cars sales team has
ever driven a supercar let alone sold
one they need to up their game
yeah i don't know an awful lot about
ferraris at the moment but obviously
have to do some research on them
supercar for anyone
again you've got to know your product
you're not going to pick that up
overnight it's a new venture for us you
know but you have to start somewhere
okay right everybody got you all
together because obviously exciting time
as you all know it's a big mountain to
climb
as well as their normal commission boss
adam is laying on a special bonus
so we're going to get 100 pound leg side
vouchers behind that card
[Music]
is kevin again um just thought i'd give
you a quick call just let me know what's
happening
spurred on by the lakeside vouchers
salesman kevin thinks he might have a
hot lead if we get a clearance all we've
got to do is really take a deposit on
this car and i'll go fill the figures
with you yeah
all right mate good we're nearly there
all right
kevin's hot lead comes good they might
want the 65 000 pound audi r8
i'll give you a call shortly see ya bye
bye
as well as shopping vouchers kevin could
earn thousands in commission making this
the biggest deal of his life
i think if we can
definitely get this guy on finance
then
is having it
this is a 365 gt c4
there's only 28 of these cars ever built
ferrari tom hartley is still working on
the deal with mr thomas
i talked about that earlier
the condition of this car is absolutely
impeccable for a 50 year old car do you
do you think you can see anything nicer
than that 50 years old i think this [ __ ]
i think we should add these um one two
three
four
five cars into the package
anyway i'm going to do a calculation for
you
has tom done enough to make mr thomas
part with his cash
[Music]
do you want to go with a 6.5 million
purchase on on these these cars that
we've talked about
we've
talked about long enough let's get on
with it you want to do that yeah
okay thank you very much pleasure
okay thank you very much simon i
appreciate that
tom's finally got his six and a half
million pound deal
hello
but he won't take the day off to
celebrate
what part of the world are you calling
from the united states but i actually
have a eurospec
ferrari f40
sorry f40 yes
tom never stops making deals this is how
it is
this is me and this is how i am tom
hartley there's always a deal any time
of the day any hour of the day if i'm in
bed if i'm in the shower if i remember
trainers if i'm having a massage if i'm
doesn't make any difference
if the deal phone rings is a deal to be
done i'll do it
tom's been told he needs to relax more
and have regular massages
[Music]
i haven't done this i've got an aneurysm
um which is four millimeters in size
i think i'd give a lot of money not to
have a four millimeter under my head
but the fact i've got i can't change
that some people want to know
but um i think about all the time
tom's meant to be having a break from
car dealing
hello
okay
put an offer to that guy on the sls
roadster tell them we'd go to
170 000 pounds
um
and we can pick up tomorrow
can we have a massage but you don't
actually seem to
the hour-long massage is only just
getting started
yeah
five hundred thousand
five hundred thousand sterling about
five hundred thousand euros
no i wouldn't take four hundred eighty
thousand 500 000 sterling
no not 490 000 500 000.
yeah no i know i appreciate it but
that's that's the price of it
do you want it yes
500 000. okay
cheers thank you very much cheers
help me through what happened it was
quite simple wasn't it that was the
place the guy do you want if you don't
want it
you're just going to be shaped to the
point and that's how it is
that's how i buy my cars that's how his
helmet costs
some people love it some people love it
next it's to the showroom to complete
the paperwork
[Music]
tom's not the only one making millions
out of supercars
the amari is at one of the most
successful supercar dealers in the
country we're dealing with supercars
you've got to be living in a super house
you're going to be wearing super clothes
you're gonna wear super watches you
gotta talk super you're gonna meet with
super people you're gonna act super you
know everything in your life has to be
super you've got to be a superman
that's what our lifestyle is super
they've spent millions on their
state-of-the-art house
yep this is all my hard work i spent
quite a long time
getting it well up to this level
it's packed full of the latest most
expensive gear we've got control 4 which
runs everything in the house so you can
control all your lights it works by our
ipads iphones we've got 3d
tvs throughout the house
so you can watch everything in 3d and
these are really cool glasses these are
the piezo resistance is sabor's ultra
modern kitchen
this is my favorite room of the house
yeah we've got around about i think 700
lights
in the now spotlights led lights oh god
i love it
i love it put the led lights on
i say if this kitchen was a car it would
be
the bugatti of all kitchens
[Music]
sabha sells millions of pounds worth of
the latest supercars every week
sabe is our super car saleswoman she
sells to the super rich
the super rich men the super rich women
she's um the heart of the business
while saba specializes in selling amari
dabbles in buying
the fact about this car is that this car
was owned by rod stewart and today
this is a cool 1.3 million
but sabha thinks he overspends i might
pay a bit more money for a car than what
i should do
once i remember i paid a million pounds
too much for a ferrari
and she hit the roof she was what the
hell have you done that for
today omari's got his eye on an old
classic ferrari i'm not keen on you
buying that car if you're honest with
you
really saba does have a reservation
about me buying classic cars you can
imagine when somebody's dealing in more
than modern supercars the everyday
supercars
she's um
she's always had a reservation about it
doesn't sound attractive to me
i think i keep amari on the straight and
narrow definitely
he's right out there so sometimes after
just
reeling back in a little bit
sabha puts her foot down amari can't
have his half million pound ferrari
[Music]
one of the uk's leading supercar
salesman tom hartley has built a
multi-million pound mansion
50 yards from it is another mansion
almost exactly the same
like his dad carl has spent millions on
his house
i designed a lot of it my wife designed
most of it everything above ground is
all my wife
below ground is is me you know
this
is known
as carlito's way as you'll see at the
top at the top of the bar
this is um this is where i come you know
i socialize my friends come around we
have a drink
you know we we had to celebrate good
deals or drown our sorrows with bad
deals it was built to the specification
being completely soundproof
so no complaints from neighbors no
complaints from me dad next door
at three o'clock in the morning because
i know it'd be like
turn it down
go to bed
along with his brother and sister carl
left primary school and joined his dad's
business
the families soon caught the media's
attention
[Music]
what's your name tom tom
carl
priscilla and uh you're all the same
family the hartley family and you you're
all in the same business aren't you
together yeah yeah
and how old are you carl seven what do
you do in the business well um when i
come home from school um i say i go in
show him see if we bought any cars or
something
i actually can't even watch this
[Laughter]
i can't even speak on it i just
know
i was only a baby i was seven
carl met his wife mitzi when they were
teenagers
your dad would show me a car that he's
bought today or sold today or or tell me
what you've done then we'd get in the
car we're gonna play golf
maybe get some food out and come back
you know just how old would you be
oh this is why this would start from
when i was six i was sick i'm sorry yeah
have you created your children in your
own image
no i wouldn't say that i would say that
they've been them
given an opportunity
to make best of um and opportunities
available to them and they've taken
advantage of that opportunity
but in bringing them into here and
training them in the hartley school's
life
you taught them
about the deal and prioritize the deal
no i i don't see how i don't see i i
taught them what what
i told them what i think they need to do
in life
i left because i wanted to leave school
i wasn't learning anything i was wasting
wasting time
for me in school
carl's been taught about the world of
supercars by the best and now he's
mainly the buyer for the business carl's
very good at his business and
predominantly he does more buying than
he does selling
but he does do both if he has to do and
he can do both
tom's illness means that he's been told
to slow down and let carl do more
i was warned by the doctors
that my lifestyle and my attitude or my
approach
maybe had to take more of a back seat
but taking a back seat is not proving
easy for tom
i love my life
i love waking up in the morning i love
challenges
i love
adventure
i love
gambling
and i love taking a risk
maybe you should slow down that tom slow
down maybe i'll take your advice
i don't think i will
so that there's no crossed wires please
put it on an email to me i will address
it as soon as possible okay it's
saturday morning and sabha omari is hard
at work in the office dealing with a
tricky customer but i need to understand
what your concern is now from what i can
understand you think you've paid over
list for the car
you haven't because the list price on
the car is 87 you've paid 82.
okay
while sabba's in preston running the
business her husband amari is down in
london at a classic supercar auction
with his sales manager ali
that's a beautiful coloured combination
i like that car as well
[Music]
i think if you cut me open
you've not got blood coming out of me
you've got super
unleaded fuel coming out me pumping out
that's a nice car though
a few years ago amari bought a ferrari
for a million pounds more than it was
worth
yeah yeah not too bad i think amari's
deals are
from the heart
and my deals are from the head
this time omari's fallen in love with a
maserati once owned by benny from 70s
pop group abba
[Music]
and then dancing queen as well yeah
dancing queen you mean give me give me
give me give me yeah yeah super nice
city summer nice city that was jimmy
jimmy jimmy jimmy give me give me give
me
[Music]
decision made the pair head off for a
bite to eat
but during lunch bidding for the abba
car gets underway
down
here's something
on the way home
yeah we'll play ours
on the way home
[Music]
but all's not lost omari falls head over
heels for a classic ferrari 246 dino gtb
it's the original color which is dino
blue
yeah very rare amari is determined not
to let this one go
[Music]
well done
amari's delighted with his new car but
now he has to convince sabha it was a
good deal
we do discuss the buying process of
course you know if i feel that a
particular car isn't going to be for us
then i'll tell him
so i'd rather not do a deal than do a
bad deal it's the original blue dino the
color
it's not it's not
spending any available
okay
i'll be a profit on this car
she kind of like flipped a little bit
but i know about the right decision all
right then see you then bye-bye bye
bye-bye
see every decision that i make is for
the betterment of the business so a bad
deal for me would be a no-go
back at big cars the grand plan to sell
supercars could be paying off
you've got to be in a different class
driving away things
terry and caz are trying out the 180 000
ferrari
just press that button there and that's
it yeah
i'll listen to this
is this what you two have coming to buy
today
now we've come into buy before focus
[Music]
james is left still chasing that elusive
supercar sale but senior salesman kevin
seems to be having better luck the next
thing we're going to do is get you
propped on fire so i need some details
from you
he's found someone who wants the audi r8
and now he's waiting for the finance to
go through
anyways good news bad news
kevin could earn thousands in commission
on this deal so he's desperate for it to
go through
but now rival adam's got a strong lead
too
we've done some figures for the finance
um good news is we can get to pretty
much where you want to be on a monthly
basis so it's coming out at 1099 a month
adam's already got someone on the r8 but
my guy could steam him first
so
it's a bit of a doggy dog situation
right okay no problem like i said we
definitely went to the best we could oh
yes but obviously
if you can't quite get to the payment
yeah it's not the end of the world adams
potential buyer drops out
cheers thanks mike
was that your main yeah oh i like that
oh baby baby
and uh
he can only get to 950 a month in touch
with him but yeah it's all on you now
mate oh my pressure's on yeah
back at home kevin has been telling his
wife claire and his daughter gracie that
he could be bringing home a large amount
of money what do you think you might
spend on
um we'd like to do some things to the
house and do the lounge and uh
yeah probably have a nice holiday
somewhere
where would you go
into florida where you'd like to go to
disneyland
uh maybe something like that
will kevin be able to seal the deal and
take his family to disneyland
[Music]
well i hope you got that on camera
supercar salesman tom hartley is
following doctor's orders
and taking some time out
[Music]
of the tiger woodshop
his sons are joining him for a round do
you think they're better at golf than
you are yeah i better go from there they
are no they never used to be
i'm getting a bit older oh and he's
better at cars house
oh
that's a silly question to ask on camera
in other words the daddy
he's supposed to see who who is better
than his dad in the car sales
nobody
tell them i said so
may be the best supercar salesman but
he's trying to take more of a back seat
in the business
[Music]
mostly buys rather than sells supercars
but today tom's letting him try to sell
a lamborghini to businessman mr white
yeah
nice to meet you i'll leave his look at
you yeah thank you
tom's going to keep out of the way
he's just got everything you know it's
just got whatever you want
yeah that's pretty funny
he a car to take his wife out and then
he needs a car take his girlfriend out
in that's the difference this is the
girl this is the girlfriend card
definitely the girlfriend car
okay mr hartley
carl's done the deal with mr white but
while they've been talking tom receives
a better offer from one of his contacts
by phone how much does he pay for this
217 000.
chief
tucci he's a friend i think you've had
too good of a deal you think i do i'm
actually tempted by buying the back off
you know if you want to sell it so if
you want to keep a quick puff on it
listen ms hartley thank you very much
but um this particular car
are you seeing you don't want the 5000
puff on the car now and even where it is
i'm saying that as much as i'd love 5
000 pounds this morning um
i think this car is for me but thank you
very much appreciate it nonetheless
so you haven't actually taken the car
the shoulder you have to just agree to
buy and i'm walking five thousand pound
profit yes you are you don't want to
take it no not today but i will give you
a call as soon as i go to sally you're
the first person i will found i promise
you that cheers thank you
tom's effort to let carl do the deal on
his own hasn't lasted long
he just can't help himself
the buzz after a deal lasts about five
seconds maybe 15 seconds
that instinct feeling
and then it disappears and you think
about getting that buzz again in the
next deal you're addicted to that bus
i think you probably am
that's the truth being on
dealmaker tom is struggling to loosen
the reins and allow carl to do more in
the business
good good yeah not bad at all
back at big cars things aren't going so
well for kevin's supercar deal
we just want commitment but you're going
to buy because all it's done to me
really really mate is i've gone into my
boss i've said yeah the man's buying the
best and it makes me look complete idiot
you can understand that
well no i it has because my boss is
saying well i thought we had this still
kevin's customer is messing him around
i give up with him i are just getting
tired of a bloke huh well we've
negotiated heavily on the price he
wanted two grand off got that for him
wanted a warranty got that for him and
now
he's faffing around he's saying there's
found somewhere local audi that's got
the same car with one owner unless miles
i'm really disappointed
but we're in this situation um you know
i want to settle the car
but kevin wants his commission
he stays late to convince the buyer to
commit
[Music]
but with no luck
[Music]
like he says i'm pissed off
we still haven't done a deal
and yeah it's getting a bit to the point
now where i just want to
chuck it all in just like take what
[Music]
it
[Music]
a fleet of extraordinary vehicles are
making their way to the mecca of
supercar enthusiasts tom hartley's show
[Music]
every year he opens his door to a group
of supercar collectors who can catch a
glimpse of his incredible garage
[Music]
tom's trying to take more of a back seat
in the business
this is a chance for son carl to shine
and be the day's main seller you're
hoping to get a few deals
yeah fingers crossed we'll get a deal or
a couple today
get their wife drunk and then they'll
let the husbands buy whatever they want
tom's wife priscilla knows it's not easy
for her husband to stay in the
background he's a self-professed deal
addict
what's it like to be to be married
on a day-to-day basis this um
up and down i suppose
you just get used to it after a while i
imagine he works pretty hard oh yeah 24
7. she said we don't go on holidays i
just moved my office to other parts of
the world
everything's
[Music]
with supercars looks wise i don't think
anything can compete with an event at
all i think that's just the best you
know full aston martin service history
and it's you know you'll like it you
don't have any problems with it
it's near the end of the day and carl's
not sold anything yet
his plan of stepping up and selling more
isn't panning out
[Music]
big cars in essex and after days of
negotiation kevin's got some news
money's money's free we just found out
it's good we're all good to go
[Music]
he sold his first ever supercar for 65
000 pounds
all right
happy with that
yeah
all right enjoy the car all right thanks
for your business and i'll support you
soon yeah
really
[ __ ] in there absolutely fine
finally finally finally five days of
house log that was that's good excellent
done it
get it on the boat oh yeah let's go and
celebrate and tick it off
right okay last part
let's put it on the ball
it's all done
[Music]
won the lakeside vouchers
and his commission
he's got thousands of pounds coming his
way
the amaris are spending their commission
from supercar sales on a
state-of-the-art showroom building is
underway
75 ferraris lamborghinis porsches
all the supercars that you can think of
you know how much i love lights
oh my god
i dread to start ordering the light
bulbs
led bulbs whatever you call them no no
what i'm going to do is
i'm going to get a led all led lights
you know everywhere it's gonna look
awesome isn't it
a few days later amari's blue ferrari a
recent auction purchase arrives
wow
look at that colour of that car do you
know blue
that's a beautiful woman
that's an old
but glamorous classy lady
starts up now
that's absolutely beautiful
now amari has to show it to his wife
saba who was furious that he bought it
in the first place
when the car arrived and it kept the
transporter
luckily she wasn't there
hi
come back thanks for you darling you're
okay
[Music]
okay
great
[Music]
sabbah checks out the dino
these cows are born to be driven born to
be
loved
born to be cherished for cared for the
works of
art what do you think of the dino it's
beautiful you like it
initially i was a little bit reluctant
about the classic cars but yeah when he
turned up or when the car turned up it
was like a pleasant surprise
and but it is a fabulous car and i
believe in amari's judgment and i'm sure
it'll be quite a rewarding investment
amari's out of the doghouse don't do it
again
don't do it again bye bye without
telling me
don't you forget that
[Music]
to celebrate being back in sabah's good
books amari is taking the blue ferrari
for a spin
there's an eight track here eric clapton
i've owned a couple of his ferraris as
well
[Music]
can you believe that's working
awesome
i feel great
i feel fantastic
i feel
super
[Music]
to put your foot down on the clutch
okay it's been three weeks since kevin
sold his first supercar
but there's some news
he's left big cars and gone to another
garage to sell family motors again
well we can do a test drive for you only
up a test drive see if you like the car
all right the dream of making big money
out of supercars wasn't for him
it's been a bit of a roller coaster i
must say yes you can do money out of it
but money's not everything is you know
it's gonna be happy with what you do as
well gotta be happy in what you do
supercars not for me
not for me at all don't do it for me
for you
no not really no yeah
but kevin's commission from the audi r8
means they're still planning on going to
disneyland
yeah
back at the hartleys and the group of
supercar collectors are preparing to go
home god love you god bless you
if you want to buy it you can if you
don't want to then i've got it for sale
anyways okay yeah no that's fine carl
wants to prove he can sell as well as
his dad but he's only got a few minutes
left to clinch a deal
and sell a car
there's a couple i think he talked about
bentley convertibles the sl-65 black
series so
you know
i've just left them to it let them look
around the car
and uh yeah they like it so
they should like the price and i think
he's coming back now
you wanna come in the office
yes
now carl's got a chance of selling two
cars
right coming to the house
he has to negotiate for half an hour
[Music]
so i think he's the uh new owner of an
sl 65 black series and a bentley v8 gtc
so yeah
it's um
good day good deal
it's a massive deal
and carl tells his dad the good news i
tell you what well done thank you it's
good well done until tomorrow
carl's got his first handshake in a long
time
but he knows his dad isn't ready to hand
over the keys to the business yet
he'll no no no he'll never leave
he's never gonna turn around one day and
say you know what
i've had enough and i'm just going to
stay at home today like that's just not
him he just he just doesn't do it
it's clear he'll have to wait quite some
time before his dad relinquishes control
for me i'll always be buying and selling
if from when i leave this
showroom in in my coffin
and i want to make sure i'm dead because
i might just put my hand down and say
deal's still available
who knows
[Music]
so
[Music]
you